we're time to try to do something where
I need to go is this happening she's got
a good luck field the more that she
experiences the more bad luck she
spreads
the Becky keeps winning bad luck will
keep spreading I miss risking again
maybe we should burn some sage anything
interesting on the news last night
you want to know what I have to say will
probably help if you can hear me
thank you tell you two things both of
which you probably already know first
this is important I am NOT the green
arrow number two photos can be doctored
they could have put Bruce Wayne's head
on that body as Bruce Wayne left Gotham
to hang out in Star City recently no now
if I was running around the city during
the day and managing it as mayor while
running around at night
frightening criminals as a vigilante
that really would make me a superhero
but I'm not I'm just the mayor thank you
very much hey everybody we got new flash
to break down and they just flat-out
confirm Batman on earth one so I think
there were a lot of Easter eggs pointing
to it over time but they just flat-out
come and say it Bruce Wayne confirmed on
earth one so who knows what they'll do
with that in the future but I think that
is just the greatest little bomb that
they could drop before this week's
episode of arrow so we'll talk more
about that when I post my arrow video
but this flash footage is teasing the
new comic book character and we're
getting Harrison wells back from earth-2
so everybody that was wondering where he
was going to come from which version of
him we'd see they've effectively
answered the question so there's a new
round of the Justice League ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video everybody's asking all kinds of
questions about Titans we have a few
answers which is actually really cool
it's exciting stuff I've also been
getting a lot of questions about legends
of tomorrow so I'll answer a couple of
those after I finish this flash stuff
but the cool thing about Becky from the
comics her name's Becky sharp but they
call her Hazzard that's sort of her
villain name is that she is a villain
but when she debuted in the comics they
never explained how she got her powers
only as you see in this trailer she has
the ability to influence probability
however she wishes but it's a little bit
different in the comics on the TV show
it seems like the way they're explaining
it is is that it's sort of a passive
ability like she just gives off this
probability field that gives her good
luck it automatically increases the
probability of
look happening in other people in the
comics it's more of a conscious thing
like she actually has a special pair of
dice which is probably what this is an
Easter Egg for but she has to choose
whether or not to give people good luck
or bad luck like all she does is
increase the likelihood that something
good or bad will happen but the way
Cisco is explaining it with this chart
here is that the field that she's
generating is slowly growing over the
city and then you see like these crazy
moments with the nail-gun the baby
Cecille and Joe's house trying to eat
them alive with bad luck which is
actually another thing - it seems like
they've officially moved in together but
the thing is is that even though she's a
villain in the comics as you can see
like there was a little bit of footage
from her in a previous trailer where
she's excited to see the flash and she's
handcuffed but then you see the flash in
the casino he's handcuffed and the thing
falls down on her she might be a villain
but in the comics she has this special
code where she doesn't want people to
get killed so when she teams up with the
injustice society it's on the condition
that they don't kill anyone it in later
adventure she actively tries to save
people from being hurt even though she's
using her powers for her own gain like
she's still a villain but the casino
stuff luck be a lady Frank Sinatra
everybody can sing the song while the
episode is happening I don't know if
they have the money to use a Frank
Sinatra song because it's really
expensive to license that music but in
the comics she had a grandfather named
the gambler and he was taken down by
this crooked casino owner so she used
her powers to take the casino owner down
and bankrupt him so I don't know if
they're gonna be doing that in the
episode they might just want the casino
because she wants to earn a lot of free
money really fast but the interesting
thing is is whether or not she is one of
the 12 people that the thinker is trying
to get like if Kilgore is test subject
number one is hazard test subject number
two and the interesting thing about that
number 12 is that there are 23 episodes
in the season so it sounds like we won't
find a test subject in every single
episode but you have to remember there's
the crossover episodes episode 13 and 14
will be a two-parter and usually it
doesn't have anything to do with a
thinker usually it's like its own
self-contained two-part story so what
might end up happening with this thinker
plot to assemble these 12 people is that
happens sometime in the middle of the
back half of the season around episode
16 or 17 he achieves whatever plan he's
trying to do and then things really go
off the rails in the last couple of
episodes like the last four or five
episodes our team flash trying to
scramble to fix things so just remember
with season 1 season 2 even season 3 the
big villain whoever that is reverse
flash or zoom or even saboteur they
usually get what they want way before
the season finale in the last couple of
episodes usually winds up being team
flash trying to rally so I'm just
expecting these 12 people to be found
around episode 16 or 17 but we'll learn
more about that as we go along like if
we get one in every single episode this
first half of the season then we'll know
what the pace is going to be Harrison
wells coming back will obviously help
out with this Hazzard problem but the
reason that he comes back they say in
the description of the episode is to
give Wally a message from jesse quick
and it's probably going to be it's not
you it's me
please don't come visit I need to break
up with you just as a reason to explain
why Jesse quick isn't in every single
episode or why Wally isn't going to
visit her all the time because this
season I think it's a lot about
developing Wally's character and you
can't really do that when he's jetting
back and forth between planets so less
jesse quick in service of more Wally
which I think people are happy about
like they want Wally to get some good
character development so for the time
being I'm assuming that she's going to
stay on earth three helping Jay Garrick
clean up that planet apparently it's
pretty bad because she's been at it for
the last year or so but this provides
the reason for Harrison wells to come
stay with team flash I don't know how
many episodes he's going to be in
because Tom Cavanagh is directing a
couple episodes there's a big reverse
flash thing that's happening later this
season that I'll talk about in a
separate video so there is a lot of very
cool Harrison Wells stuff happening in
the first half of the season but because
so many of you were like yes please do
that reverse flash video that will
probably post this weekend sometime I'm
still doing a Q&A video for flash and
arrow stuff that'll probably post on
Friday if things don't get really crazy
stranger things is dropping this Friday
so I'll probably do an episode 1 video
but after that hopefully the schedule
will balance out a little
in Walking Dead premieres this weekend
too so there's gonna be some extra stuff
happening this weekend but for those you
asking about Danny Trejo he's confirmed
for Episode four that's also when the
elongated man is going to debut or he
might debut at the end of episode three
like he walks into the episode and then
we meet him full-on in episode four but
episode four is called elongated journey
in tonight so obviously that's going to
be all about him but for those of you
asking about what's going on with
legends of tomorrow they just
reintroduced kuwasa who's vixens
granddaughter her other granddaughter so
there are two versions of vixen on the
TV show there's maori who we met during
arrow season four but for those of you
wondering who it was emerged from the
lake at the end of episode two of
Legends that was kuwasa so she's going
to be part of the villain team-up the
thing is is that the person in the hood
is not the big villain
she was resurrecting kuwasa in the name
of malice
so malice is the name of the big villain
on legends of tomorrow this season we
don't know anything about them and
they're not a character from the comics
at least the name isn't a name from the
comics later today I have a Titans video
to post they just confirmed who's
playing Beast Boy meaning that we know
who all the Titans are they cast their
entire team so that video will come in a
couple hours I also know what the
episode schedule is going to be so all
kinds of really awesome Titan stuff is
coming up you gotta have a power
something cool something you turn into
animals man that's beyond cool thanks
but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Mike John please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for my episode 2
video and you can click here for that
season 4 Bart Allen reverse-flash scene
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight